[Music]
so
[Applause]
hey everybody welcome to an official led
live
and happy
almost reformation day
we're going to get into this discussion
today you guys um because we get a lot
of questions with our ministry um over
these kind of topics and so that's kind
of what we're here for right we're doing
research for you oh you maybe don't even
know what topic we're gonna talk about
halloween
all right if you have any questions on
halloween actually we requested the
question so a lot of these kind of came
from you guys but i want to introduce to
you brittany um we shoot these shows
sometimes like a lot of them at once and
uh we actually shot a show where we
introduced brittany which we haven't
released yet so um
you've probably seen her popping in and
out of the shows and so we want to
officially welcome you to the show even
though you've worked with us for months
now but two months yes yes yes hello
everyone yes britney does our graphic
design for us so a lot of these awesome
graphics they come from britney so
that's right thank you for that you may
have already interacted with her on
social media because she helps with that
as well yeah that's true that's true so
let's uh dive into this uh
i don't know what the best place to
start is but uh we'll let you kind of
take it away here
all right so the first question that we
have is what is the origin of halloween
and how did it come to the u.s okay i
guess that's me i'm up hey everyone
um so i'm actually also the one in the
chat and as we discuss and say different
things not only will we have slides but
i'll also be putting all of our
reference links or at least the ones
that
are available to me yeah i'll put those
in the chat so you can follow along
because we literally just look this
stuff up and we're here to present it to
you today so yeah my question oh and if
you guys have a bible also you know
follow along with us read the bible uh
pick out the verses that were we're
saying as you can mark them down or or
something like that would be a good idea
so the origins of halloween how far back
do you think this goes thousands of
years thousands yes that's correct
you think it started before or after
christ came to this earth before yeah
before that's true
back in the third century bce
the the celtics so now i've been saying
celtics my whole life that's incorrect
it's the celtics so
there it is the celtics had a festival
they called um so in but that's spelled
a i s-a-m-h-a-i-n
so um now this religion the celtics
could be found in places like england
and northern france and ireland within
the celtics the
what you would call the priests or the
teachers these people were called the
druids and i wonder if that rings a bell
to you guys
the druids
would actually light bonfires now these
bonfires they weren't like oh let's put
some sticks together and light up light
it on fire no they were actually like
wooden cages that were like that look
like humans and within these cages were
actual humans and they set these things
ablaze just to give a little insight as
to
what these druids
i believed
post the link here for you guys
here is the origins this is from
history.com
there you go but i'll read the quote
it says pliny the elder and pliny is
just a he's a historian
he wrote of the druid's appreciation for
both the mistletoe cough cough but we'll
stay on topic here and human sacrifice
to murder a man was to do the act of
highest
devoteness he wrote
wow you guys catch that and to eat his
flesh was to secure the highest
blessings of health have mercy
tacticus even described a battle in
wales in which the judes covered their
altars with the blood of captives and
consulted their deities through human
entrails
so that's what we're dealing with here
the druids who loved blood and gore and
that is not an understatement at all so
while the celtics were doing those
things over there
catholics in the 8th century through
pope gregory iii designated november 1st
as a time to honor all saints now soon
all saints day incorporated some of the
traditions of sowen from the celtics and
the druids and the evening before
october 31st was known as all hallows
eve which today is known as halloween
which leads us into the next question
okay well how did halloween end up in
the us
well through the european immigrants
they brought it their traditions and
their practices when they came to the
new world
back during the times of like the
pilgrims and people trying to escape
famines and religious persecution well
they brought all these ideas and
practices with them
very very wow for me dark
past you know it's interesting that a
lot of these things that we um
you know have in our modern world it's
like they have these really dark origins
yes and we're not exempt just because we
don't know we should be looking up these
things right right the blessing of the
internet actually you can find out some
of these things um so you know can't
claim ignorance really in this world yep
all right
so the next question um why do people
disguise and ask for candy
so um during my research um there's
actually this article from
history.com in 2019 it's titled how
trick or treating became a halloween
tradition
and so um in 1000 ad poor people would
go to the homes of wealthy people and
they would um
in exchange for
soul cakes which is
these pastries that were given out on
halloween
the poor would offer to pray for the
wealthy families deceased members
and then later this was um later taken
up by children and so that's when they
started giving out food money and ale
and then um in scotland and ireland
children actually started dressing up
themselves disguising themselves and
instead of praying for the dead or
pledging to pray for the dead what they
would do was sing a song recite a poem
or they would do like some sort of like
trick or like some type of trick and
then for them like collecting the treat
um and so what we have today is
basically a evolution of the past
um and i think it's interesting because
it's like we've almost tried to remove
the roots to make it more comfortable
for us
you know it's crazy but um
yeah this goes back all the way to like
the middle ages so it's been around for
a very very long time so yeah what we do
today is just an evolution of that
next question can christians celebrate
halloween
all right i guess i'm up um so the short
answer which you're not going to like is
yes but let me clarify okay
everybody drops off
the bible um in a couple of places paul
actually mentions this in in first
corinthians one and chapter ten and one
in chapter six what i'm going here is a
principle okay context talks about
um in one of them it's christians who
are
uh taking other christians to the legal
system of the day and he's saying really
you should handle these things in church
but he says this twice he says that all
things are lawful for me
but
not all things are helpful
right or not all things are edifying and
he also says in in first corinthians six
he he kind of clarifies that
um he says i will not be brought under
the power
of any
okay
so there are things that he's saying
well yeah it's lawful
but you could be brought into the power
of something just because it's lawful it
doesn't mean that you should so i want
to clarify that further with a couple of
other texts
james 2 12 says so speak and so do as
those who will be judged by the law of
liberty
right
and galatians 5 1 says stand fast
therefore in the liberty by which christ
has made us free and do not be entangled
again with the yoke of bondage
so as christians we
have freedom because christ has paid the
penalty for our sin right
and
we've always really had this freedom of
choice
but we've been freed from the bondage
and the power of sin
and so when it comes to things that
could keep us
in bondage
yes we're free but we should avoid going
back into bondage if that makes sense
so is it something that we can do yes
it's something that we can do on a
technicality yes i can do that the
question i think is more should we
well if it's something that's going to
bring you under bondage things that are
going to be um sinful then definitely we
should
not right we shouldn't be brought under
the power of those things
um ephesians 5 11 of course we've quoted
this many times in the history of this
ministry and have no fellowship with the
works of darkness but rather expose them
i think the king james even says the
unfruitful works of darkness
um i used to have a boss who would um
razz me about my diet and i was eating
you know whole food plant-based diet and
he would
we'd have some company thing going on
and he would say well you can't eat that
and i always used to correct him i
always used to say
actually i can eat that
but i choose not to because i know it's
not good for me so on the technicality
you can do all kinds of things you have
the freedom and the power of choice to
do that
should you
well the bible speaks to those things as
well the things that you should and
shouldn't do
so
anyway hmm i think that might that's
what made sense to me anyway yeah no
good good good thoughts i mean that just
kind of makes you say you know god we
live in a world where god is allowing
you the choice to engage in the things
of this world or not and it's like you
know he's he's basically not just
binding you he's giving you that
opportunity right
so this next question says why is the
church so quiet when it comes to this
unholy day
so personally my church was not silent
about this at all they definitely talked
about it had seminars they were pretty
open like this is an evil holiday do not
celebrate it i better not catch you at
my door with a little basket asking for
candy
um and so this is also this is clear to
me through my church and also through my
home my mom always like she raised me
like teaching me um that halloween was
not something that we celebrated so it
was never practiced in our home and so i
think that um sometimes when we talk
about the church
we often forget that we make it up as
individuals and so our education
ultimately should come from our home
first and foremost so if we each make
the choice ourselves to not celebrate
halloween that is that's something that
can um unify the body of christ you know
so it's not really
yeah i don't know maybe some churches
don't talk about it but mine definitely
has so i don't know if i can group this
in a collective thing can i challenge
you for a second um you know obviously
being a young person growing up in the
church how did the young people receive
those kind of messages
i mean we just kind of grew up with it
you know i
i mean i i did attend like a fall
festival but it wasn't an adventist
church it was a baptist church and i was
just going with my friend
but
yeah we just didn't celebrate it was
just just stay home turn off the lights
so the kids didn't really rebel against
it so to say well i don't know what they
did at home personally but i just we
just didn't do things like that yeah so
yeah just in my personal experience so
yeah
cool
good answer
um so the next this next question says
lots of christians say that as long as
you don't take part in the satanic
practices it's okay to celebrate
halloween do you agree with this
no
no we did not agree with this
but it was an interesting question
which led me to another question like
how do you celebrate something without
taking part in it um so i don't really
know where this person is coming from
but i couldn't really reconcile that
like you know how do you say that we're
celebrating this holiday but not
partaking in in the holiday um
but i'd just like to bring up this bible
text uh first thessalonians chapter 5
verse 22 it says abstain from all
appearances of evil so it's not
necessarily just the evil thing it's
also the appearance of such things
an example that i love to
use is decorating your home
if the outside of your home is decorated
for halloween but on the inside you're
not
participating in halloween how will the
person on the outside know what's going
on in your house so to circle back and
invite that person to church or any kind
of religious event it could
form conflicting ideas for that person
because no one is
inside your home but people form
opinions and views based off of
appearances so just to be mindful of
that another verse i love is joshua 23
verses 13 through 16
which in synopsis is saying guard the
avenues of your soul
but then it keeps going god says
love god your god because if you wander
off and start taking up with these
remaining nations still among you
know for certain that god your god will
not rid these nations of you
they'll be nothing but trouble to you
don't you love the bible like it's just
straight up this is what happened
happens and it's not even like oh it's
saying it's going to happen and it never
did happen we have the israelites track
record
of what was happening anyway i won't
ramble on and on but joshua 23 is an
excellent chapter to to consider
because the devil is just looking for
any opportunity and so when you think of
the
practices of hollowing the activity they
all have a purpose so just because
you don't want that purpose to happen or
you're hiding under the cloak of
christianity doesn't stop um the the
consequences of engaging in those things
and i'll give you an example um
the
activity of
let's say um carving pumpkins right it's
an activity that can be looked at as
innocent it's one that could say you
could say oh we're not
celebrating halloween it's more of like
a fall festival type of vibe or you know
something like that well
the question should always be where did
it stem from what is the purpose of it
what is attached to it so i believe i
posted the link in the chat history.com
legend of the stingy jack and i just
want to read the story because
oh i shouldn't say it's funny but it is
a little bit but just considering the
history of it three paragraphs i'll be
fast
people have been making jack-o'-lanterns
at halloween for centuries the practice
originated from an irish myth about a
man nicknamed stingy jack according to
the story stindy stingy jack invited the
devil to have a drink with him true to
his name stingy jack didn't want to pay
for his drinks so he convinced the devil
to turn himself into a coin that jack
could use to buy their drinks once the
devil did so jack decided to keep the
money and he put it in his pocket next
to a silver cross which prevented the
devil from changing back into his
original form
jack
eventually
freed the devil under the condition that
he could not bother
bother jack for one year and that jack
should he die
um the devil would not claim his soul
the next year jack again tricked the
devil into
okay
just reading this jack tricked the devil
to climb into a tree to pick a piece of
fruit while the devil was in the tree
jack carved a sign of a cross into the
tree's bark so that the devil couldn't
come down until it until the devil
promised jack not to bother him for ten
more years
soon after jack died as the legend goes
god did not allow such an unsavory
figure into heaven this is jack we're
talking about so jack wasn't allowed in
heaven the devil upset by the trick jack
played on him
and keeping his word not to claim his
soul would not allow jack into hell so
now you just have this spirit floating
around
um so
he sent jack off into the dark knight
with only a burning coal to light his
way jack put the coal in a carved out
turnip and has been roaming the earth
ever since
the irish began to refer to this ghostly
figure as jack of the lantern and then
simply jack-o'-lantern right
so
in this legend you have the spirit
roaming around and you have these
lanterns now can you picture a christian
carving a pumpkin and putting it in
front of their door
what message is that sending not just to
us humans but the spirit world again the
devil is just looking for an entrance
into our lives we need to be on guard
wow that's crazy yeah
actually it doesn't matter um about the
design because you obviously have the
pumpkins with like the triangle eyes and
the evil smiles but let's say what if
you were doing something with flowers is
it just the pumpkin
itself being carved and on the holiday
associated with it or is it
a specific image that you carve out of
it um no the image doesn't matter but i
think i will say this context matters
because if you're going to say oh we're
going to do this activity and we're
going to specifically do it around
halloween that's an issue but like in
april if you have this
they use turnips potatoes if you just
have this fruit just making a carving
out of
anything that's not demonic it's not
doesn't have some dark hidden meaning
but context context is everything you
can't take away the name but still be
within the context of something and then
think it's all right
yeah we can't like outwit the devil
wow interesting yeah and also i mean if
you
you have kids if you tell the kids hey
we're going to do this activity host i
mean they're going to be racing like you
know when they're gonna be you know
fifteen eight
yeah
so this next question is um is it okay
to say happy halloween just to be nice i
wanted to ask dude to me not liking the
holiday
hmm
yeah you know i mean i think like if you
don't support and you don't agree with
the day um you know i i think just sort
of like engaging in it in a in a in a
way that you would
you know just sort of like i don't know
i think it's a statement to not say that
you know what i mean and if i disagree
with it and people are running around
going happy halloween and it's like
happy reformation day you know people
are gonna be like well what do you mean
by that you know like uh i think you can
use it as a as a point to kind of show
where you stand with it
and then also um you know might spark an
interesting conversation um but yeah i
don't i don't necessarily agree with
saying uh happy halloween i think you
can be nice
you should always be nice right
no matter how people are you don't want
to offend them you know
so uh
you know i i jot it down just a couple
verses here i wanted to read to you um
for this um
ephesians 4 32 says be kind to one
another tenderhearted forgiving one
another as christ has forgiven you
right you know you think about that like
like you know don't just run around and
condemn people because there's probably
a lot of stuff that we could be
condemned for so we want to be just be
nice in general we want to constantly
always um you know
give give people the the you know the
golden rule right romans 12 10 love one
another and bro brotherly affection and
outdo one another in showing honor like
you know like like always strive to to
to build bridges not burn them down you
know what i mean right
yeah
i guess you also kind of answered this
next question which is how do i approach
fellow believers that participate in
pagan holidays well i mean i would just
tell them right off the bat like what do
you like satan
oh no maybe that's probably not the
right approach
you don't once again you don't want to
just immediately
offend for the sake of offending i think
that you can be clear in your message
you can be clear in your stance without
like making other people just
immediately awkward i mean um you know
carry around tracks at just how evil
halloween is and hand it to him
yeah i agree i i
cause i
know
you know i would love i mean you came
for that person it's like hey bro i mean
you didn't know about this stuff for me
why you did that exactly nice way you
always want to look for an occasion to
to um to share right right but i think
sometimes we can run around and beat
people over the head with the truth
right and i think that it's not as
productive as waiting for the holy
spirit to actually
work out a scenario to where somebody
would be like hey i said happy halloween
you said something different like well
why there's something rude yeah you know
what i mean like is that sometimes we
wait for people to be in the midst of it
to say something and how messed up is
that they're enjoying themselves doing
whatever then you come in as like a
downer and be like oh this is terrible
that should be a discussion
from way before
whenever the opportunity shows itself we
shouldn't be waiting for yeah sometimes
you can't help it you know like if
you're at the grocery store it's a cash
register i mean
and they're like happy halloween you
know well yeah but i'm just talking
about addressing it in general yeah with
your friend group
family yes i i yeah i was at a table one
time with um a bunch of vegans and um
they had we were at this place that was
serving us so you know we weren't in
control of the food and they set down a
dessert that had chocolate in it
and one of the guys that was sitting at
the table i mean he grabbed out that
piece of chocolate and he threw it on
the table and was just like i just
cannot believe they would serve us
chocolate
wow and i was just like are you gonna
eat that
but i just i think that it set this tone
at the table that if anybody was there
that maybe
just saw differently with it with a
health issue they would not approach
that guy and ask him for anything yeah
so i think the the the the lesson that
we can draw out of that is like you know
god will provide ways for us to engage
with our co-workers engage with people
that participate in this and maybe open
up the door for an opportunity for us to
discuss
where the origins or or you know what
some of these things were but let the
holy spirit lay those times out yeah
people were attracted to jesus they
found him beautiful they wanted to be in
his company you know that's the way we
need to be the things that we believe
and espouse we should be attractive
people to other people not and i'm not
talking about physical beauty it's like
who we are should be attract right
right and it makes me think of um
mary when she
or when the pharisees had brought her in
to be
stoned
and jesus didn't focus on the
prostitution party you know and so she
became one of his most devoted followers
so
yeah we definitely need to give people
grace because i know like sometimes
people who do celebrate halloween they
have probably haven't done exhaustive
research on it so they're in a way
innocently
celebrating it but yeah the information
is there for all of us but we should
definitely offer grace
next question is it wrong for churches
to do a fall festival on the night of
halloween to get the kids off of the
street at night
yeah that was a great question right
i remember when i was a kid that
actually happened there was a church i
was going to and they had something
going on and
you know went to church instead of
being on the streets for
halloween
but i've also been trick-or-treating and
all that you know i mean in my life it's
been different things at different times
um
yeah we actually got several variations
of this a question and i guess that's
the first thing i would say is
like we've been talking about
it's important not to assume motive
right you don't want to go to your
church and be like well
you guys are just idiots you know for
taking the kids off the street you know
somebody very
it's not that their logical conclusion
is correct
but they may be thinking
something like well gotta do something
if i don't do something then they're
gonna be on the street
wouldn't it be better for them to be
here it's a perfectly
you might say logical or kind or
reasonable motive right like well yeah
we don't want them on the street so we
will do something at church
but that's also easy to fall into
a bit of a trap because
two wrongs don't make it right right you
know
and the lesser of two evils is still you
know evil
at the end of the day
but don't but don't approach people like
you know
hammer them and i said this the other
day in in in worship here it's like to a
hammer everything's a nail right
so be gentle with people um
likely the problem with this type of
situation is that the church sees itself
as competing with the world and as
christians oftentimes we have that
mindset as well
we need to learn to educate with the
right mindset
and so
i'm just going to ask a couple of
questions for you guys to think about
one is
is your mindset i can't
or i choose not to
right that's actually a really excellent
oh yeah i can't do this i hear this all
the time people are accusing christians
of you can't do this and you can't do
that or they'll even say it themselves i
can't do this or i can't do that no no
no what's your mindset is it i can't or
i choose not to
right
um
and then ask yourself why do i choose to
do the things that i do why am i
choosing that way there must be a reason
right and that reason should be founded
on biblical principles along with those
questions do i see myself as an oddity
have i espoused a mindset where i am
just totally estranged from everyone
around me and it comes out in my
personality it comes out in my speech it
comes out in my lifestyle to the point
where people are like
yeah that guy's just weird and i would
never approach him i would never ask him
any questions i would never
yeah you're just strange like
you know and you're such an odd you know
bird
that
it's unattractive to people right which
is is pushing them away
do i wear the badge of scorn
presumed
or otherwise
on a chip of my shoulder
sometimes we walk around and it's like
you know we we
assume we know what other people think
about us
it's like well
well those christians you know and so
you get a chip on your shoulder and it's
like well i'm just i'm gonna score i'm
gonna score i'm just gonna be angry
about this whole thing and tell
everybody what they shouldn't do
that's not attractive
right
um
so on the flip side of that do i
approach these things with
joy and peace
and an invitation to something better if
people see there's something better
inside of you if you have something to
offer them if you can talk to them about
halloween in a way that they've never
heard of that is you know extremely
attractive
that draws people that's what jesus did
he drew people in
and then they were like man whatever
that guy has i want that
and then the other things they don't
even matter
right they fall away
so just to kind of further clarify
there's nothing
wrong with gathering on any particular
day for
like
just gathering
going back to what kindy said is what's
the context right why are you gathering
what's the whole purpose of your
gathering right
you know
so are you getting together at church
take for example you have halloween
and you get your church together and you
fast and pray is there something wrong
with that
because it's halloween
no
what if there's kids there
nothing wrong with that right it's the
context what are you doing are you doing
all the same things that you would do
outside
now we have to reevaluate our situation
because it's not any different you've
just changed the location right
i i for our church
they actually do a fall festival and um
it's really neat it's like a barn party
um in fact if i didn't know what day it
was around or coming up near
i wouldn't even associate the two
together whatsoever because it's like
people show up with cowboy hats and
boots and there's a you know band with a
banjo and that kind of stuff and and um
they have games and food and you know
everybody brings something and it's like
this time for our whole church to get
together and um they share testimonies
and sing songs together and often it's
you know like hems and things like that
so um i think that there is a an
appropriate
means to do something that um you know
gets the church families together and
and could potentially just you know
steer them totally away from this thing
yep yeah
yeah it's uh
because i bang around with a
different
you know
churches and i know that they do
for the children you know candy and they
dress up maybe not for like evil stuff
you know ghosts and dracula and all
stuff but they dress up like you know uh
doctors
you know things like that it's not evil
and
uh you know some people what do you guys
think about that well it's interesting
in the research it wasn't that the
druids and these other people were
dressing up as something specific
to ward off the devils
they were just dressing up in costumes
period warding off the devils that's why
you have a choice as to whatever you
want to dress up in what's the purpose
of dressing up yeah right that's the
question yeah and it it just makes me
think is is it just an alternative to
this holiday because let's say you want
you're like your kids may feel left out
from the world and you got that candy
free right and you don't want them to
rebel so you're like all right let's
find a nice alternative so i guess is it
okay to make
alternatives of
evil holidays i guess or pagan holidays
like a veggie halloween
but you're still celebrating it on
halloween you know that's the thing like
it's like a fall festival what's the
difference between it and
august versus in i think there is a
danger of of really making something so
close but it's just kind of slightly off
that like you said when your kids all of
a sudden get up to the certain age that
they're going to be able to choose i
guarantee you they're going to be
confronted with this topic and so it's
like well i've been celebrating it sort
of in this you know
yeah this sort of like might as well
just join it yeah right you know it's
it's a simple step into the other one
whereas i really appreciate that the
approach of just saying you know hey you
can be
um you know uh don't don't have to
engage in it whatsoever at all and then
you know or making it something special
always around that particular time right
a friend of mine was saying that um they
took their their kids camping that
weekend but it's also something that
they did that they do throughout the
year but their whole thing is they
wanted to remove their kids from that
altogether they didn't want to deal with
like their doorbell being wrong
in brazil they do this a lot during the
the festivals that happen um called
carnival um the whole church just to get
the church together
they go up into these retreat areas in
the mountains and things like this and
and the purpose is really to remove the
church members from the either the
temptation or whatever and it's like
then they have like you know games and
things like this so you know one could
look at that and be like oh you're just
making a church version of that up in
the mountains but it's like no we're not
it's it's like totally different and the
purpose of it is to really offer
something that doesn't you know leave
you to be tempted to do that right right
i asked my youngest daughter i don't
know
this past week and i asked her i was
like hey yeah
how do you feel that
that you never
celebrate halloween
you know now that you look older
do you think you miss out something you
know maybe
you know young kids you know around
school
and he said no why i need to celebrate
that
yeah yeah
yeah great input
um
so this next question is how did
halloween become mainstream even among
christians
so we kind of touched on this in the
very beginning um
i i hate to throw a church under the bus
but sorry catholicism um was one that
really started blending a lot of this
um
you know they basically their motive in
the very beginning was
was really you could say um probably a a
good motive where they were like hey how
can we witness to people and incorporate
them but i think that
they were doing a double negative here
and by creating a place where you're
engaging in it and making it comfortable
then all of a sudden it's like now
you've you've got this problem on your
hands because you can't quite say this
is evil or of the devil if you're out
there condoning it you know what i mean
so pope gregory um
the first he was the one that really
kind of first started incorporating that
into the um
the um the whole scene and i think you
might have a couple slides in here
there's pope gregory the first right
here i find it very interesting like you
know this really super dark picture of
the pope um you know you you'd think
that this person would would be uh
someone that's representing religious
ideas and heaven and god and you know
it's just interesting that they that
they portrayed it in this way but go
ahead and click to the next slide so if
you want to look into this more into
this connection so it's not just us
saying this um the history channel
actually has a whole article on there
about how really the catholic church is
the one that sort of christianized
halloween and um sort of put the rubber
stamp on it that it was okay and and
really that's kind of in our modern
world that's how we
er christians began to sort of blur the
lines here uh coming from what kennedy
shared at the beginning where it was
really a druid a cult uh you know a
witchcraft like people stared clear of
that kind of thing um when the church
puts its stamp on there um
you know there there this is this is an
example of how it becomes dangerous when
we as the church put our rubber stamp of
approval onto certain things where it
kind of comes to
and so um you guys can look that up uh
the link uh hopefully will be in the
description there or just google the
history channel uh or the history.com
the early catholic church how it
christianized halloween
it's interesting how the gnostic or
maybe also the new age of you is kind of
seen all throughout this because we're
putting ourselves in the place of god if
you have um the day before where you
ward off the evil spirits so you can
have all saints day the next day well
it's not our job to be warding off
spirits it's gods
we don't have the power to do that right
and then bringing in all the saints well
that just goes into the
um
the state of the dead
which is a whole another topic i
understand that but yeah just
just being careful not to put ourselves
on the pedestal even on the same level
as god by engaging in these things
and justifying it as it being for our
good because it's not i would agree yeah
so what is halloween what is the meaning
of the halloween
hallow means something that's like
saying something respected right and
um i don't remember the blend yeah it
was like um
the
wean part of it came from i think the
eve right thing so the original was all
hallows
halloween yeah yeah interesting in
mexico halloween
uh
well we don't translate you know
literally like like you were saying but
like we call it the knights of the
witches
or the witch's day
well yeah so i mean parties just like
you know the nights of the witches you
know halloween and there's a little
witch you know on the back of the name
or something like that party the night
before show up smash the next morning
yeah
um
on that topic though this next question
is can you please highlight the cultural
pitfalls like via de los muertos yeah
day of the dead
i see it is a huge deal especially
around mexican culture in california
yeah i mean it's a huge thing i mean
it's it's not just like oh it's a party
or something like that it's part of the
culture
and it's kind of like memorial day you
know here
uh but it can be like two different
things you know you can go to the
cemetery and and
clean up and think about bringing roses
or you know flowers and
and stuff like that
but the thing is that the day of the day
is like celebration of the dead you know
this it's kind of like respect
to the death
but the thing is that at night time is a
different things you know uh so it's
more
rituals and and more a little dark
and i mean it's a huge party you know in
mexico it's a huge party
and respect dead and stuff like that but
the thing is they the evil spirit i mean
the evil people they practice that kind
of stuff witchcraft and everything
that's a perfect time to you know
around the world to you know do do
do
animal sacrificial and all this is crazy
stuff but it's a it's a it's a big thing
you know i didn't grow up with that
culture
because
i grew up christian and we didn't do
that kind of stuff
and they do some candles and altars and
put pictures and
and that's for the dead people you know
and my my parents will tell me that we
don't we don't need to
mess around with with that you know with
that kind of practices they the devil
and all stuff but i remember uh one time
i really celebrate and i push my parents
to because i saw my my friends they were
celebrating that and i was like please i
really want to go hang out with my
friends and my mom is like please don't
don't let my son to go and my dad was
like okay that's fine
just one time but that time that i went
hang out with them and you know all the
the party thing it just drew me i really
enjoy it
and later on when i was growing up i
mean i was
i was every year hang out and and i
think
that yeah it's it's a cool thing when
you say the day of the day i mean it's
part of mexico thing and if you don't
celebrate it's kind of like weird like
what's wrong with you right well the
devil is let's do this the devil is
clever and you know if if he can wrap in
some sort of
cultural emotional thing like can you
think about it like why would you not
want to respect someone that you've
loved and that lived on this planet or
whatever like that and then to rip rope
it into that it's pretty sinister but
then look at what he's done with
halloween it's like you've taken this
really evil day and you've now made it
about cute kids dressing up and they're
so cute and you want to see them cute
you know it's like the devil is just
really clever on getting you involved in
his thing yeah right yeah and i think
it's
super important to focus more on christ
during that time because the world
obviously is
putting us in this mindset of halloween
so i mean every commercial right now
every disney abc family which is now i
think free form everything is showing
just scary movies right now so they're
clearly getting us in this mindset for
an entire month you know so i think it's
definitely a time to just lean in closer
to christ
talk about commercials uh this morning
my wife sharon share with me a
commercial up
tricks no tricks the cereal the cereal
no that the candy the chocolate oh
yeah
so twix have you guys seen the new one
commercial about halloween special
actually i think it i it wasn't the with
the witch yeah
maybe we're going to do another show
about a music reaction but it's like
pushing agenda
for
young kids
and witches and all stuff it was
it was crazy
who who was telling me that there was
you had some statistics i don't remember
which one of you girls um how many ouija
boards are put on the shelf or like
there's more
that are sold at this time of the year
than anything else
i didn't have a statistics i just went
out to um the store and i saw just a
bunch of ouija boards on the show that
was it and it's walmart
no it was it was like tj maxx or girls
or something yeah but isn't that
interesting that like all of a sudden at
this time of the year it's like yeah all
this just evil stuff just gets thrown
out there i heard a statistic um how
many how many
outfits are sold in the u.s for
pets
490 million dollars really 490
million dollars that's a lot don't look
cute that's so much money like i i think
i remember seeing assistance of what it
would cost um to
help um world hunger and it was like in
the 300 million range i mean that's like
wow you've sunk it for a year right yeah
not to solve it forever but so chase out
this is well i don't know if it's in
statistics but in manhattan new york
they're renting a huge building i'm sure
you guys see this store before the
spirit of halloween or halloween spirit
that they said oh yeah
you know outfit yeah it opens around
here too about that time yeah that time
the just for renting that month the
is is uh uh it costs thirty thousand
dollars wow for one month for the
building for the building wow but they
pay yeah they barely bring some money
because people are gonna go with it but
30 000 a month
yeah man
you actually have a really uh a quote
after did you do you want to read it yes
yes i i saw it so to me it's all so
amazing
how the dark world
that you know they do things but let me
tell you they they telling the truth uh
uh
anton lavey
the founder of the satanist church right
yes and it says i'm glad the christian
parents i mean can you imagine that guy
said i'm so happy the christian parents
let their children
worship the devil at least just just one
night bro
i mean you just work you let your kids
worship
satan for one night and that's october
31st i mean can you imagine that the
founder yeah i mean it's not some good
in the yeah corner that doesn't really
tell you where this is all leading um i
was actually
watching this testimony of
this ex-satanist i can't remember his
first name but his last name is ramirez
yeah maybe john ramirez and he was
saying that um he said you know
all while i was a satanist i never saw
like
like none of us would ever just say oh i
think i'm gonna go to church and
celebrate easter that's right you know
like they just didn't celebrate
christian holidays like that so it's
like it's crazy that as christians
we just openly celebrate or we want to
celebrate satanic holiday yes satan if
they don't go to church at least on fri
a good friday right that's what he was
saying right and also he was saying uh
john ramirez i mean really
amazing testimony
uh i just want to bring this thing the
candies i mean that guy he was
practitioned satanist i mean more than
25 or 30 years or something and he said
he said
that they
they pray over those candidates witches
they pray over those candies
and sometimes like why are my children
acting like that i mean of course you
know sugar high
but
talk about the uh
the evil you know i mean the darkness of
the uh of the world
they act like that too i mean
that's a good point this state is bad
because that also speaks to how much we
believe our own religion because you
think we pray we pray before we start
the show we pray over the tracks we give
out saying the holy spirit please go
with this and press upon this person's
heart
the devil can do that too and if we
believe it's working outside it's also
working on his side so it is true and
then you talk about like oh is it sony
studios that pray over the records of
the music
capital records john talked about that
wow
stuff is happening it is careful it's
right
all right next question tips on what to
say to co-workers that ask why i don't
celebrate halloween because i don't like
satan
i mean here's the bible tracks you want
to read about it
no i'm just kidding
i i think that literally save that sound
bite and just play it
literally i think that
once again here's an opportunity for you
to really engage with your co-workers in
an intimate way
and um you know if they ask and they're
coming to you i mean pray that the holy
spirit gives you those little divine
moments but here also what i want to
encourage you
don't be an ignorant christian
do some research that's right look it up
i mean look at what we've well look at
what we've been finding out and and you
know the questions come we do a little
bit of research and we're like okay what
does the bible say about this and that
know what you're gonna say because every
year this may potentially come up in
your workplace so do a little research
have an answer like what the bible says
always have an answer and be ready to
give that answer to somebody because
that may be the thing that sparks them
to say you know what i i what else do
you know about the bible you know yeah
right right and there's something
powerful in our lives being a witness
that we are faithfully devoted to christ
and
don't partake in things that we don't
believe in just
just in our faith
like he'd say you know
we choose i mean we can we can tolerate
you know why i choose not to celebrate
you know and a nice way to build bridges
no yep
this person coming to you i'm guessing
they noticed something about you that's
different you don't celebrate it you
didn't say happy halloween whatever and
so when they're coming to you and asking
you for information now it's time for
you to say hey i do have something would
you really like to know why i don't
totally right
yeah yeah well my next question because
there's the the one go to the next one
right so that's keith's the one after oh
yeah the one that says how can we handle
looking weird i think that ties in great
with the one you just answered scotty um
you want to read the question oh right
so this question is how can we handle
when we look weird due to not
celebrating halloween
yeah so yeah you can have all the
answers you want and
handle it perfectly but you're still in
a sense removed from all of that it
could be look like you're an outcast or
whatever the case it can be
quote-unquote weird well looking weird
uh yay it's a regular occurrence for a
bible-believing christian
part it's okay like it's not something
we should be afraid of um and we should
stand our ground just like jesus did
right and despite jesus standing his
ground people were still attracted to
him that's right you know they still
were drawn to him so that's some
encouragement um our consistency is our
greatest witness so that's another thing
like it's one thing to say no and then
kind of participate in it or like you
kind of lose
um the power of your no the power of
your explanation um
by by not being consistent with it
so um also when it comes to what you
have to say if people are coming at you
any kind of way saying that you're
overreacting or what you're saying is
crazy
you could pull up history.com national
geographic say this is straight facts
you're calling me crazy are you calling
history crazy yeah and just have
something to back yourself up and what's
sometimes nice about that is it's not
always coming from oh you're just crazy
christians are saying this no that's
that's a you know historical factor
where this stuff comes from right and
they're not trying to influence you
whether you're not for against
christianity so right you know sometimes
it's good to look at other sources other
than just what the bible says because
maybe there's not common ground there
that people would see that i do have a
question though marilyn gave us a super
chat yay thank you marilyn
um and what she's asking is what about
christians who dress up
as the bible characters to take back
halloween what would you say to that
yeah
so we did address that earlier when when
alex was was sharing his thing and i was
saying that um it doesn't really matter
what you dress up as the point is that
you're dressing up and that activity was
used by the druids to ward off evil
spirits to ward up demons so it doesn't
matter how you participate it's the fact
that you are participating it doesn't
remove the consequence it doesn't remove
satan giving having an opportunity to
enter into that space so i just just
stay away yeah i would i would almost
agree i i think sometimes just trying to
find a way to engage in that activity
i know it's going to spark a
conversation obviously you're running
around and who are you oh i'm john the
baptist
hmm
you know like like you may you may have
some some some good interaction there i
don't know but um i think once again i
think the most powerful statement we can
do as christians is to not engage in
these things right because i think it
can be confusing like
you know because then you have someone
say oh well i have a friend who's a
christian and they celebrate halloween
so why don't you and it just puts a lot
of confusion in the church you know so i
think it's important to be consistent
right and what if like oh i became a
christian by
meeting someone while they were
trick-or-treating but i can't
trick-or-treat anymore so i guess i
can't bring other people like it's like
um bring some using a means to bring
someone in but then turning around and
telling them to never do that means
again right it's conflicting ideas yeah
i have a question uh how you
when
knocking the door i mean if you're there
i mean it is wrong to give maybe not
candy maybe a piece of fruit or that's
actually originally what they used to
give or what's called those toothbrush
that's good i'll go for toothpaste
before they were giving out candy they
would give out fruit specifically
afterwards
yeah oh yeah yeah
yeah um
so
okay hold on okay with this question
so yeah the next question is what is the
best thing to do on that day october
31st as christians instead of just
staying indoors ignoring the reality
that is going on outside great question
it is a great question i actually like
the way that one was put yeah
so i'll answer with another question
what's the best thing to do on any day
right
oftentimes we we
we let
days or times dictate who we are or what
we do
and as christians we should be found to
be consistent right
it didn't matter to daniel that
a law was passed he was still going to
pray
right
it shouldn't matter to us like well what
what the day is not day of the week not
holiday
our first and and and
foremost thought should be is my life
dedicated to christ today this is the
only day that you have that you know
that you have
you may not even not even have the whole
day right
you're not guaranteed tomorrow
so what's the best thing you can do the
best thing you can do is be consecrated
to christ that day right in everything
that you do
um in addition to that
you know i would say it's a great day to
talk about the reformation we've kind of
already mentioned that
and um we've already talked about you
know making your beliefs attractive if
you're just tuning in we've talked about
making your beliefs attracted attractive
uh your beliefs and your your
personality the way you interact with
people should be full of hope and joy
right you should have an answer for them
but i want to i want to speak to a
couple of things that i think are kind
of ironic
about halloween and just people in
general
um first of all how halloween happens to
coincide with flu season
is that a coincidence i don't know we're
handing out a bunch of candy as a flu
virus is probably coming around
and you're gonna tank your immune system
or your kids
um
we also live in in western society at
least western society we're very broken
right
and
we often mask who we are
and going around and putting in costumes
on or masks on is is really kind of like
a metaphor for i'm masking who i am it's
it shows that i'm not satisfied with who
i am a lot of times
there's some um
you know if if we have christ we don't
have to mask
anything we can just be in him
and dissatisfaction with who we are
oftentimes drives us to
substances in this case i don't know
maybe it's driving us to candy you know
make us feel a little better we get a
sugar rush
but um those two things at least in my
mind they're kind of interesting
metaphors for just how we are in western
society we often mask ourselves and we
often go to something to make us happy
and it's almost like we're being primed
for that on on helen ween yeah it's okay
to mask who you are and go get something
that tastes sweet problem is
candy tastes good but it doesn't satisfy
right and that's much of life there's a
lot of things that we can do in life
they might feel good it might taste good
the experience might be great but they
don't satisfy because they haven't
they're not rooted in christ
so
yeah
free response
so um
this next question says why do some
christians hate on horror movies and
christians like me that like horror
genre
so this hit a personal
a personal accord for me because i
loved horror movies i mean i've seen
insidious the grudge conjuring american
horror story i mean name it i've seen it
and um
number i mean it wasn't up until like
last year that i just really felt
convicted not to watch it anymore and
the reasons are number one it glorifies
satan
glorifies death sexual immorality i mean
they will literally have like sex
rituals
you know and it's just not something
that is godly and it also um promotes
fear
and so scary movies to me are like
satan's ministry and do you really want
to support it you know like
we're focusing on him he wants us to do
that and then it starts to affect you
know like
now you can't sleep in the dark anymore
because you feel like something's under
your bed or in your closet or that coat
suddenly looks like this scary figure
you know and it's just and if the bible
speaks against fear why are we putting
ourselves in it
so um there was a bible verse james 4
verse 7 which says submit yourselves
therefore to god resist the devil and he
will flee from you when you're watching
scary movies you're not resisting him
you're being entertained by him and he
loves that because the more you focus on
satan the less you're going to be
focusing on christ and it's kind of like
satan's power becomes greater you know
in a way over your life um there's also
first peter 5 verses 8 to 9 which says
be sober minded and be watchful the
enemy prowls like a roaring lion seeking
someone to destroy and devour
so those are just some things to keep in
mind horror movies i mean just the whole
killing in general is against the
commandments so it's just not something
that i think a christian should watch um
especially if we're just we're supposed
to be used for godly purposes and ex and
we don't want to expose ourselves to
these things so yeah amen totally well
speaking of killing
i gotta get out of here
yeah my my wife and i are going on a
marriage retreat right now and so i'm
watching this clock going i gotta get
out of here
but you guys are welcome to stay and
continue the conversation do you want to
do you want to keep going you you have
you know a little bit more to go i got
to get going soon too okay what time do
you want to put off
we can get off any time 115. as we
deliberate in front of our viewers
i'm really surprised about brittany's
last answer because right before the
show we had to like bring her down
almost handed her a paper bag she was
like
nearly hyperventilating
so the fact that she would even watch a
scary movie i find really interesting
yeah well i think it's very big of you
also to be as transparent and open and
honest because we want you guys to know
as well like we're in this we're in this
mess as well we're battling and
struggling through some of these things
as well so i really appreciate your
honesty and coming to the table and i
like the fact that god has convicted you
on that um you know uh
i know which point you were convicted on
and and i think it's it's it's really
amazing but also um sometimes god
doesn't want us to go through those
things but he can use our experience of
going through those to help other people
that are stuck in that same thing
so um if anybody out there is in this
same boat trust me there's light at the
end of the channel there is there is and
your mind can be renewed i cannot walk
those things the same anymore it just
makes me sick because of my stomach
um i mean we can yeah you got to go but
if you guys want to continue over
another day
right there
okay well there's actually one question
okay one more one of us um which is
actually
i believe it's the last
one isn't going away yeah halloween
isn't going away so how can we
creatively transform it
ooh that's my question philosophical uh
hold on one second where are we at well
i i don't wanna i don't wanna uh skip
over um keith maybe talk a little bit
about what the actual 31st was
for a second what do you mean
yeah i'm not wasn't like 31st actually
the reformation day yes oh 17th
yeah it's sad to me that the devil is
always changing the meaning of something
no it wasn't or the first in the third
semester
no i mean you're tearing about two
different things you're talking about
origins of halloween about reformation
day the devil takes something that he
already had
right so the reformation came afterwards
in in some ways yeah it's just depending
on how you look at it
in one way it's like putting a nail in
the devil's coffin right yeah um
so yeah 31st reformation day this is the
day that martin luther nailed the 95
theses to the uh cathedral in wittenberg
in germany and it was from that that the
protestant reformation spring important
thing i think to remember and all of
that is martin luther was a
a very devoted
catholic monk you know he did not hate
his church he didn't he wasn't trying to
really say anything bad about his church
he wasn't trying to like bring his
church down what he was trying to do is
help transform the mindset of those who
were
in it you know and and with him and he
just had questions that he wanted
answers eventually it drove him
you know away from that
because he couldn't he got to the point
where he could reconcile the two and
that's where we have you know
protestantism springing from and of
course since then protestantism has
branched off you know from lutherans and
then calvinists and you know baptists
and anabaptists and so on and so forth
uh amish and all kinds of stuff
um yeah that was so there's a creative
way to transform it learn about some
some alternate thing that happened on
that day and you know make some
make some uh you know go to your church
and and share with you that positive
information around that time frame and
just you know maybe some some way of
trying to take people's mind away from
the evil in the dark but sort of like
focus on the light and show something
amazing that happened around that same
time but that doesn't mean you dress up
as martin luther and nail 95 these days
no probably not
a good idea at that time of the year
right
it might be a bad taste
yeah
well here here in my in my notes here i
compared trying to transform halloween
to trying to transform the government as
christians i don't think that's our
mission
um jesus came to earth and his mission
was to reach the heart the heart of the
individual actually not the heart of the
system
so when it comes to
what we should be changing it's
individuals and as individuals change
then the culture changes and so on and
so forth so jesus didn't partake in a
lot of the things that's right this
world was doing but yet he was so
attractive yeah so i agree with you
focus on promoting the good and then the
bad will naturally dissipate yeah
great point to end on
thank you guys for watching and
obviously we
literally go through every comment that
you guys uh give in there we actually
spend a lot of time doing that so thank
you guys for actually giving us these
questions um we hope that they did some
justice we cut out probably three
quarters of them right
at that time yeah it's we didn't this
would be a six hour show if we literally
handled all the comments so we kind of
pick and choose choose but if there's
something that you really want addressed
feel free to put that in the comments
below and uh if you haven't subscribed
to our ministry please do so share our
content it's no good sitting on the
shelf right
get it out to people and um i hope the
one thing that you take away from this
conversation is
use every opportunity that you can to
build a bridge win a soul and to share
the love of christ with somebody even in
this dark day
that's what people are focusing on they
need to see the light of christ and we
hope that you'll do that today yeah
we'll see you guys next friday thanks
for watching
[Music]
you